another element of unfortunate reality
is that this morning Donald Trump
devolved into a childish tweet storm
appearing to potentially even have a
psychotic break of some kind maybe under
pressure from the coronavirus fiasco and
once again proving that we are at public
health risk by having this man as
president and at least nominally in
charge of the coronavirus response you
know if it's really Jared Kushner
behind-the-scenes or whoever it's bad no
matter what Trump is at least nominally
in charge look at what the president has
spent the morning tweeting first
attacking news coverage on MSNBC saying
watched the first five minutes of poorly
rated morning psycho on MSDN see just to
see if he is as nuts as people are
saying he's worse such hatred and
contempt I used to do his show all the
time before the 2016 election then cut
him off wasn't worth the effort his mind
is shot then remember that yesterday
nearly 2,000 Americans died yesterday
the death toll was right around 1950
Trump insists everything is fine and
tweets quote it's amazing that I became
president of the United States with such
a totally corrupt and dishonest
lamestream media going after me all day
and all night either I'm really good far
better than the fake news wants to admit
or they don't have nearly the power as
once thought then as the official number
of cases in the United States will pass
800,000 today Trump tweets about his
ratings saying quote I've had great
ratings my whole life there's nothing
unusual about that for me the White
House news conference ratings are
through the roof Monday Night Football
bachelor finale New York Times but I
don't care about that I care about going
around the fake news to the people
remember that the daily press briefings
are some of the most lie riddled public
facing events that Donald Trump has done
in his presidency and then lastly once
again from tweeting about these phantom
approval ratings among Republicans we
never know where they're coming from I
think they might come from just surveys
that Donald Trump promotes through
YouTube channels
saying quote 96 percent approval rating
in the Republican Party thank you this
must also mean that most importantly we
are doing a good great job in the
handling of the pandemic now the truth
is the opposite in the last gallop
presidential approval poll I told you
about this yesterday a Trump's approval
dropped nine points since the last poll
that's the fastest approval decline
between polls of Donald Trump's entire
presidency but none of it matters it's
all a question of what can his followers
be convinced of nearly 2,000 people died
yesterday were passing 800,000 cases
today testing has not actually increased
for weeks and Trump spends the morning
bragging about ratings and attacking
Mika Brzezinski and Joe Scarborough
MSNBC hosts this is not a president
maybe someday we will have one I'm
really excited that one of our sponsors
today is helix sleep I sleep on a helix
mattress at home I absolutely love it
and that's why I reached out to them
about sponsoring the David Pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me I didn't
know what I actually needed I didn't
know what I would like but helix has a
sleep quiz on their website you tell
them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness I generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress hilux was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both GQ and Wired magazine it
is well deserved I can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty you can try the
mattress risk-free for 100 nights and
they will even come pick it up at your
house if you don't love it but I know
you will all of my viewers will get up
to two hundred dollars off your order
and you'll get two super premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
under
this video